In this problem, we take in a list p, and we want to return the greatest value in p.
We're given that the list is positive integers.
We're going to choose 0 to start out greatest value,
because 0 is smaller than any positive integer.
Additionally, if we're given an empty list, we're told in the instructions to return 0.
This will be useful later.
This is similar to the previous question where we want to go through the list one entry at a time.
If we find an entry in our list that's greater than our current running biggest,
then we want to update biggest.
At the end we're going to return our max value.
The problem specifically asks for you to deal with the empty list case,
and if you noticed, if p is empty we don't execute any of this.
So the end result is that this is equivalent to just returning 0,
which satisfies the problem constraints.